Після провалу першого етапу вторгнення в Україну Росія змінила свою воєнну тактику,
зосередившись, зокрема, на невеликій території на Донеччині, де російська армія за рахунок своєї вогневої міці повільно просувається вперед,
- зазначають німецькі експерти.
Під час так званої другої фази війни, де увага зосереджена на Донбасі, російські сили доклали зусиль,
щоб не повторювати помилок, яких вони припустилися під час першої фази.
Тому ми бачимо менше недоліків у логістиці, хоч вони все ще є.
В даний час ми бачимо, що бойові дії ведуться на невеликих ділянках, на яких зосереджено велику вогневу міць,
коли російська армія намагається пробити противника, так би мовити, вогневим валом.
Зараз точаться запеклі бої за Сєвєродонецьк і Лисичанськ, українські військові змушені поступово відступати перед силами,
що їх перевершують, на сході України.
Експерти не відкидають ймовірності, що Росії вдасться захопити Луганську та Донецьку область,
відвоювати які Україні буде неймовірно важко.
Західні експерти вважають, що українська армія не зможе військовим шляхом витіснити російських солдатів
зі своєї території, включно з Донбасом та Кримом.
Єдиним, що могло б призвести до цього, був би добровільний відступ Росії з внутрішньополітичних причин,
або тому що треті сторони чинять на неї занадто великий тиск.
Але навіть це абсолютно точно не поширюватиметься на Крим, упевнений експерт.
Російські війська перевершують українські сили за кількістю артилерії в 20 разів, а за запасами боєприпасів - у 40 разів,
повідомило днями британське видання "Індепендент" із посиланням на звіт розвідки.
Крім того, українські сили обмежені радіусом дії артилерії в 25 кілометрів, тоді як російські військові можуть завдавати ударів з відстані, яка у 12 разів більша.
Однак у Росії поступово закінчуються сучасні високоточні ракети, зазначають експерти.
Так напередодні з'явилося повідомлення про те, що з Іркутська, а це за 5 тисяч кілометрів,
зі складів було вивезено ракетні установки, які мають бути доставлені в Україну.
Ані Київ, ані Москва зараз не зацікавлені у мирних переговорах, оскільки обидві сторони вважають,
що ще можуть перемогти супротивника на полі бою, - кажуть експерти.
При цьому вони зазначають, що для української сторони стало ще складніше погодитись на компроміс
після воєнних злочинів у Бучі та інших містечках на північ від Києва.
Перспектив повної поразки я не бачу для жодної зі сторін, тим більше необхідні зараз мирні переговори.
Найсумніше - що наприкінці будь-якої війни найчастіше доходять висновку, який можна було б зробити вже на самому початку:
про те, що існують компромісні рішення, про які можна було б домовитися і без такої кількості жертв.
Війни закінчуються переговорами, колись треба їх розпочати.
Це знає і президент Зеленський, це знає населення України.
Прагнення добитися повної поразки Росії німецькі експерти вважають безглуздим та небезпечним.
Мовляв, тоді може скластися ситуація, в якій Росія відчує екзистенційну загрозу для себе, а це означало б ескалацію війни.